parce que là on est on est en on est en
roue libre là mathieu on a un fou pour
les candidats un bain dans we total à
moi j'ai pu la chemise toi non plus si
asile et j'aurais même famille le talus
le fus dessus moi je suis en tee shirt
et donc dans la rue
j'étais un pull à capuche à 3 minutes
mais vers lequel m comines et également
oui je reste en tee shirt blanc attend
je viens m comme il faut on va laisser
les genres arriver on va voir s'il ya
beaucoup de monde qui participent à ces
paquets lol temps - je les nie à 12h15
d'accord mais on peut s'inscrire pendant
en fait d'accord ah oui oui c'est ce
qu'on admire ouais c'est l' avantage de
ces tournois en mode arène c'est que ça
permet de de laisser le voyage de
commencer le tournoi une heure à une
heure et puis de laisser les gens après
s'inscrire comme ils veulent quoi tu
vois ces histoires de garder un peu le
rythme des candidats d'avoir quand même
les petits strips de 12h à 14h je pense
ça peut être sympa pour après ouais
c'est là tout le monde va se lâcher en
ce moment ouais bon alors je vous ai lit
en fond pendant en attendant le début
des candidats vont discuter avec les
gens on explique comment ça se passe et
on attend les vues des candidats mans en
étant le début de la reine il ya un
match qui se joue en ce moment
narrow contre
les peaux non666 ces salles romanes ça
donc ils sont chauds d'un prend 1 cape
town peau s'ils ne prennent pas en fait
préparer ils viennent de kate
ils y viennent en mai genk aline trede à
mach 4 food étroit possible il faut
aussi vous regardez au port on peut
regarder après tranquillement l'un me a
decade tout cas le score est serré un
cc66 pour le moment mais c'est un match
de comme le bras comme ça je pense
qu'ils sont en délire il ya une époque
est en train de stream et yann à roanne
ce trio adam dieu ce qui doit il était
hyper malades tranquille quoi voyait un
rom comme honnêtement 82% des joueurs
d'échecs longtemps - dans ma part j'ai
fait cinq ans d'affilée longue j'ai été
mal ans malade cinq ans et tu joue moins
bien quand tu es malade ou même pas
forcément forcément mal mais j'avais
préféré gagner cela génère il ya ces
vieux mage avait fait sa dernière nombre
de grands maîtres à l'époque à romont et
j'avais trouvé ce moment là déjà eu dans
le jeu c'est arrivé j'ai quand j'étais
tout petit j'avais fait la guerre aux
flottes j'ai fait un super temps mais
j'avais dû rater une ronde parce que
j'étais malade ce qui m'est jamais
arrivé de ma vie de travailler pour
l'hérault flotte et j'ai raté la norme
parce que j'ai juste fait un forfait
sinon je faisais les normes de prêt donc
vraiment rien dire well as mois après on
vaut mieux être en bonne forme à cela
mais c'est pas non plus rédhibitoire à
part londres
j'ai remarqué quand on est enrhumé et
plus concentrés sur l'aspect sur
l'échiquier comme tel à tapas de force
pour le oui c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est
marrant cette partie va je viens et +4
non aya kefu prend 1,3 ouhlala oui c'est
en fait parce que ça marchait pas son
idée lobbys et des syndicats
il faut prendre trop de problèmes
sanguins mois il était obligé parce que
sinon tu te trompes et du coup c'est pas
si clair l attaque à cinq et menaces
cavaliers c'est que ménard aussi un gros
joueur quand même je trouve
oui c'est un saint talent car il a pas
j'ai pas le meilleur du monde mais ça
mexes un talent - m avait dominé dans
une fois j'avais fait un peu mieux sans
risque et je me suis fait dominer sans
risque et l'emploi les choses très vite
un excellent envie de ça à mon avis tu
vois dans un speech championship
il pourrait être plus dangereux que que
certains mecs du top qui prennent pas le
mal qu'ils prennent pas les matches au
sérieux
soit 1 à rognan moi je vais peut-être
plutôt dit oui de base mais à un loyer
ouailles il est bizarre ne sais pas
pourquoi ils progressent plus pour moi
en blitz
mais même un aronian t'as pas tort mais
il peut peut-être même plus dangereux
qu'un art hogan
mais il me fait penser un peu à moussa
en france ouais mais qui voit tout très
vite qu'ils jouent bien que dangereux
enfin sur une partie peut pas vraiment
tout le monde mais il est plus fort
ménard or il est plus fort mais oui mais
c'est le même profil way ménard au il a
taquiné les 27 n'ont longues années 50
il s'est arrêté mais peut-être mais il
fait ses études lui fait il fallait pas
du tout joueur professionnel naroff
il fait des études sepa sepa standford
d'une faillite fait une très grosse
université il fait des très grosses
études en réalité bon en ce moment il
fait que streaming
oui mais parce que gueye sais que tu es
tu veux aller chercher à temps et si le
fait ouais parle de ça c'est le genre de
coup hyper dur à voir faut il faut y
penser tout bas sur la presse était
peut-être qu'on musée accueille ses
quatre premiers 3 mais au coude avant
d'ailleurs il y avait peut être aussi
fou en étroit mais je voulais faire
qu'ils allaient prendre les deux noeuds
ça marchait pas du tout dans tout
reprend en c3 tour d un jeu des fonds
d'écran et des deux comment est-ce qui
peut rentrer là bas et ce tour au 6e
tour v6 pour claquer nom sympa où là il
ya un an elle veut prendre de la togruta
d'm6 mathieu on arrive à les faire dame
voiture il n'empêche j'ai une
notification
on est là il c'est une bonne nouvelle
ce football là je me suis plongé les
notifs en tant qu'anti ça s'arrête a eu
des bons des bons retours de nos
commentaires mais jean ricoux alors
franchement ouais il est quelques élèves
qu'on regarde été la grosse vidéo j'ai
fait là celle qui me tenait à coeur
ouais il nous dit pas mal parce que ça
veut dire baisser et il ya aussi hier
jérôme à tempe en a 2 nuls
non c'est pas nul cent six nuls 3 et
joue pas le nul du panel arrive la gagne
oui il a raison parce que tu en prends
un autre des quatre saga c'est
maintenant un primo nous mais tu vois
cette vidéo à tous les duels papa du
marché tout en réalité les gens ils le
regardent
aïe ça j'aime regarder les nuls les
chiffres on relève une donation à 5 mais
ouais bah il commence à avoir du plomb
dans l'oeil du pion il va là il va la
perdre
narrow ya trop de points c'est quoi les
10 secondes contre 20 mai grosse défense
donné pour en mai serait malade de
journaux
voilà les questions après heat et ça
peut évacuer une frustration
voilà les deux nouveaux perdant n'est
pas mais l'auteur ouais mais bienvenue
est tombé 4 quoique risques seront
perdants pour les blancs oui séjour joue
vite en art aux enfants de maintenance
et plus bardon séguin
ces deux nouveaux à ta vie prend pas la
tour c'est vraiment un troll vers
gardien 15e à wes les rotules abattu il
ya plus de l'aude alerte à lui c'était
chaud il a regardé incombe bien comment
ça marche c'est quoi le concept je sais
pas il ya il ya une époque écrit hockey
cinq scénarios qu'il écrit no more le
fief yourself en 3ème mec maroci tact au
génie lsa ça veut dire ça aussi j'ai pas
le droit
ça c'est genre en russie c'est conduire
dornach un mec est tous allemands et qui
veut pas rejoué tu peux lui dire tu peux
lui dire ça comme ça
ce qui est un peu de monde y en a qui ne
montent dans le tchat ce qu'on a pensé
les messages de manioc cèdera d'abord
sur twitter je passe pas suivi un peu
que j'ai pas suivi
j'ai pas tué je suis assez d'accord avec
les deux environnements le côté de que
radhi était pas hyper à fond - helmand
je prends un peu après par contre de jeu
pour le pro aussi quand il dit qu'il a
travaillé pendant un mois
il a dit qu'il avait pris quand même car
jaeckin et 2015 comme second temps à
2010 ça m'a surpris parce qu'il me
semblait qu'il bossait pourquoi
mais non je le crois un petit mais ce
qu'ils venaient pour la gagne mais après
magnus je sais pas ce que j'ai vu je
sais pas si c'est vrai que je veux tu
pourras me confirmer qu'ils disent que
ils avaient peur d'y aller macha et tous
deux dans quel sens que rajab dit que si
ç'avait été magnifié de rue perdue elle
ouais ni deux tu parles d autres noms
mais après ma news 10 qui comprend le
fait de pas vouloir y aller mais le fait
de le faire comme ça c'est super mais je
n'ai pas entendu un seul à toi mais pour
un job c'est pas le sait pas l'humilité
incarner un ils ont un peu enfin pas
tous faits y en a quand même certains
après c'est normal aussi que un peu la
grosse tête
rajab or ce qu'on disait ce que tu avais
expliqué je crois d'emballage de le mec
il est marié à quelqu'un qui a beaucoup
d'argent
ces groupes pacifistes à une vie de
famille les échecs même si son métier
c'est sa vie c'est sûr qu'ils aiment le
jeu s'agit à aucun autre mais c'est
quand même un peu au second plan depuis
quelques temps plein je crois que c'est
l'fun et je crois qu'il est marié avec
la fille du gars qui à la société socar
peut-être tu connais avec cabaret
sponsor de l'équipe
c'est un gros truc donc forcément a
forcément il a des gros moyens pas oui
voilà donc il aurait de quoi travailler
pour le tournoi mais aussi la de quad
c'est pas sa priorité que les échecs de
niveau ça demande beaucoup et à l'époque
où il était au niveau pas vraiment au
niveau cela il est remonté top 9 me l'a
pas joué pendant deux ans il était très
fort mais on a vu qu'il a pas réussi à
tenir le cas jean relais on avait parlé
dans le là étaient des candidats d'avant
ça a été une déception le radulov de jpk
l'année c'est 2013
13h - attendez-vous
je sais mais elle est arrivée mais
visiblement il y est passée par là
malheureusement pas tant mieux parce que
tu avais vu le tweet de carmona disant
qu'elles sont requête annuler ouais mais
il avait la story instagram un peu plus
tard et sarah quoi il est assez bien
comme il faut dans l'avion où elle met
en plus avaient l'air d'être un avion
privé non c'était un avion privé est
très clairement très clairement pour
mieux ouais bah tant mieux qu'ils se
reposent
parce que mine de rien il aimait un rush
de fou au niveau émotionnel et même
physique qui se repose et qui digèrent
ce
très bon débutants 1 et après lui la
parole d'affaires il va voir ce qui va
se passer
il aura son mot à dire mais c'est pas
lui qui décidera donc quand ça s'arrête
pas trop d'énergie là dessus il peut
travailler plus sérieusement plus
sereinement
tu penses que les résultats du tournoi
vont rester tel quel ou qui aura encore
d'inventer un en théorie oui c'est le
règlement mais juste est-ce que l'ofc va
m'appeler ses avocats porter plainte
il avait l'air des terminales ferrières
en tout cas dans l'interviewer a déjà
pas mal mais si le tournoi est allé
jusqu'au bout est ce qu'il aurait fait
quelque chose
non non mais après il a dit beaucoup de
trucs très sensée par l'interview
l'histoire du ministre russe etc
mais je pense ça serait intéressant de
faire une timeline de tout ça mais je
pense ça va aller je pense qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui va le faire en tout cas ce
que je dis ça parce que mine de rien que
ce café l'auriculaire de dire non le
tournant a déjà commencé sachant que la
première n'a pas eu lieu il y avait
juste sur la simulation
c'est sur le cndd à melen tous les cas
lui quand il est parti du temps moi
c'était avant le truc du ministre russe
ferment mais peut-être qu'il peut
essayer de jouer sur le véhicule tournoi
était illégal ou ce genre de choses
aussi la radio phase i qui pourraient
son avocat mais les poissons ne pas
faire des choses c'était le règlement et
j'ai aussi dit qu'il ose du qu'il avait
dit que son son avocat est en
quarantaine aussi après le fait que
quand ils te dis moi j'ai eu des
informations de gens qui m'ont dit que
c'était beaucoup plus grave le corona
qu'on le disait tous mais dans ces cas
là et en russie oui mais ça ils
angoissent à tous les autres joueurs on
en discute non il son argument sur le
fait qu'ils trouvent ça pas normal de
contacter les autres je le comprends
mais je saurai donc très bien joué ça
d'être pas son argument c'est de dire si
c'était quoi déjà c'était de dire que si
que si le
il contactait les autres ça allait faire
un genre de mutinerie quoi ouais on
comme s'ils voulaient pas prendre leur
pause it et sur lui de faire annuler le
temps à mais un peu comme marot il le
défonce à mais c'est quand tu dis no
more et tu reviens en général ça se
passe mal sinon sur la piste à la gare
pour toi et je suis pas sûr qu'on puisse
le jouer depuis la puye rasolo il ya
beaucoup moins de monde que les autres
jours les gens sont moins connectés avec
1 800 personnes s'étaient connectés pour
le pour le petit pour notre petit live
web je sais ça devait être les gens il
va avoir pris l'habitude quoi cela il ya
dix neuf non pas pour le patio toi je
voulais dire soit le et sur le tournant
on était une petite tête un peu moins
d'une centaine mais je pense que c'est
parce que les gens ils avaient pris
l'habitude mais il est là il pense que
ton mal fini le ski est pas faux
derrière mais ouais mais peut-être que
tu as beaucoup de gens qui venaient pour
poursuivre quand même plutôt les
candidats il ya juste ont regardé un peu
et puis après il reste par inertie j'ai
envie de dire salut latendresse salut du
à 69 libye nous engueuler auxilois et
libye hier ils tirent à balles réelles
quoi pourquoi bas il était très énervé
des camps village sais pas mais il
engueulait aussi les mets que bah ouais
les mecs qui étaient pas énervé du coup
mais robert s était très énervé aussi un
ouais j'aime bien du coup j'étais pas
sur ta chaine peu après j'étais sûr
confie ciel les deux je sais très bien
ce qu'ils ont fait d'inviter tout le
monde est de donner là où moi et ça
c'est bien je trouve qu'ils ont fait
mais ce serait bien à illifaut faire non
pousse à vous avez genre assez neutre ce
n'était pas forcément facile parce que
j'imagine qu'ils ont à tout le monde a
son avis là dessus ouais ouais non ils
ont été assez neutre surtout surtout
daniel à robert lui il avait du mal j'ai
un peu discuté avec lui dans la nuit
cette niche un peu discute avec robert
en fait ben et
ouais il était robert il était vraiment
énervé quoi c'était pas du fake mais
contre l'avis des contres suite offs qui
surtout pas plus contre l'argumentaire
que contre le fait que le tournoi a eu
lieu ou quoi mais plus large
je sais qu'un trait politicarde de dire
tout ce qu'on fait c'est bien même quand
il a dit qu'un truc bien c'est qu'il a
dit que la cérémonie d'ouverture et
adultes comme ça c'est le seul truc
positif de son message
ouais je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
toi c'était assez positif et il a
reconnu le tort de la cérémonie après
moi je sors pas compris le fond la
sphère pourquoi le temps a été annulée
honnêtement ça c'est quelque chose
d'unique au beach il dit clairement que
c'est à cause de ce truc d'avion ouais
mais les avions tu peux tu peux affrété
un jet privé encore s il aussi l'espace
aérien est fermé même un neuvième
prévenue peu pantois non mais c'est pas
l'espace aérien sont les vols réguliers
c'est pas les seuls j'aime beaucoup ça
laisse de l'espace et le vol régulier
donc vu de l'espace aérien n'est pas
n'est pas fermée c'est juste les vols
réguliers je ne comprends pas vraiment
alors après ils te disent oui mais il ya
[Musique]
j'ai vu après sur le facebook de stop
stick y avait beaucoup d'officiels
différent des arbitres qui avait pas que
les joueurs mais bon tu peux faire
affrété un vol pour pour 50 personnes et
tuent les arènes à angres en europe
bon puisque en plus question est ce que
c'est la plus chère de refaire le tour -
ce que j'imagine qu'ils vont demander
des dédommagements aux pois j'espère oui
bon on verra en tout cas mais mais j'ai
je suis pas convaincu de l'argument
officiel ce que je me demande s'il n'a
pas autre chose quoi même mais autre
chose ce serait juste un cas est pas le
seul on avait des doutes ces dépôts et
il n'est en train de baisser
ouais ou alors un cas ou alors des cas
ekatérinbourg plus généralement où on
n'en sait rien tout prend 3 intéressant
pour la casquette mais pas obliger un
hobby mais dans l'absolu je suis ramené
un cavalier sur des six c'est plutôt pas
mal mais il aurait peut-être dû prendre
deux noms se lie à peut-être four b3 et
jouets bon burger qui est maître fide
je sais pas qui on ne connaît pas
l'identité de la personne mais ça
devrait pas un bon joueur en forcément
de 3 c'est l'automne peut mieux pour les
blancs là d'un le fou pour revenir sur
deux à cause de la cazassus faut faire
gaffe qu'il y avait eu 4 mais tu peux
aussi te de cloaque dmb 2,60 euros
tu peux aller vers à trois jours des
positions ont alors fait un garrot coup
là je vois le fond bleu en fait quand
pas je pense qu'il faut le garder c'est
qu'une noire son compte en échanger des
pièces qu'ils ont toutes ses pulsions
c'est sûr très solides points noirs
s'ils n'ont pas vraiment de nouvelles
suisse mais le fait qu'on ait jeu de b
6e tendance à penser que ça peut être un
peu mieux pour la blanche qu'est ce
qu'un masque parce qu'une fois foods de
f3 fougères fois ici sur choses comme ça
il faut deux fronts c'est un très bon
[Musique]
appareil photo paraît sympa moi elle ce
que toi aussi tu joues pour la colonne
et même après je peux je foutais de f3
gucci pour contre la casse après sur f3
les noirs doivent aussi les 2,5 pour
trouver du contrôle jeu sur les cannois
parce que le focac blanche rend ainsi ce
sera un peu de l'autre côté
as tu commencé parfois à 6 d'art à 3 qui
est b5 times un club où je le fous en d2
mais quand tu vas te [ __ ] des quatre
tours ce set plutôt logique
ouais je voudrais quand même le fois à
six personnes
après peut-être qu'ils se sont fait
juste engueuler par le gouvernement
russe non seulement par poutine
ouais c'est possible non mais ça serait
une saran plairait beaucoup de cases
ils peuvent pas le dire oui il a fait
arrêter le tournage non mais a peut-être
aussi le truc qui a un autre tournoi
d'échecs à mourmansk qui a rapporté le
coronavirus dans une ville et
quand même d'un point de vue
communication par rapport au fait déjà
trois échecs à porter le virus dans une
ville
bon ça peut ça peut jouer dans ton
argumentaire quoi de dire les gars vous
avez déjà un peu déconné la sara quoi et
pourquoi je remets le lien du du tournoi
ça je crois qu'il ya un truc drôle c'est
que je crois que je connais un évêque
qui jouent en direct l'un il y adeux
mais crée m'immerge doit couper le son
parce que c'est le contrat que je triche
il m'envoya messager du goût elle et
blanc je connais les blancs les arbres
et maître fide on est d'accord
ouais c'est toujours mieux
la r3 faisait 3 avec un seul set tout
des finales boîte un peu mieux à chaque
famille jouer ces temps là non à ses
débuts difficiles mais eux cinq sont
bons réflexes de son intérieur 23 47
passe mal les bons réflexes parce qu'il
faut trouver dieu contre jeu même si
objectivement un micro pas trop c'est ce
que je veux dire c'est un bon toucher de
pièces bah tu dois tu dois changer le
cours de la partie quoi c'est ça dans
toi tu aimes ce set c'est un peu dans
l'hymne et c'est bien mais j'en prends 1
5 ans elle a quand même du mal à prendre
à l'attaquant malinois j'aurai comme ça
franchement je vais un petit fond c'est
même certain
ouais tour en d1 comme est hors jeu 5 il
est hyper de tanger simple dont je sais
que ça fait vraiment peur ouais je crois
c'est comme une vraie manne serait je
fais quand même barrage 3 f4 web ont
peut-être fait un peu peur oui voilà
mais oui je suis d'abord c'est un peu un
peu trop posthume à présent longueuil
était ici c'est prendre ça aussi dans
l'idée c'est quand même je pense que
c'est correct
j'allais dire fou beckham
amis pouvaient pas intercalé prise
sommes d'abord wave and night est juste
prendre cinq tours c1 il à la colonne
maison st ça fait encore non mais tu en
as fougue et 8.7 aussi on va faire garde
qu'un à tour à trois fauves et cinq à
six qui peuvent être une idée de défense
plan prenant mais je sais ce qui s'y
sont un coût 5
when you know me douche froide à ben
ouais reste ours et les tours ce set
mais vraiment peut-être foutraque qui
règne en le 4e tour à 3 l'accord des
cinq frères et il dépend encore avec les
noirs non il est seul à partir d'un
moine et vous tâtez chaque mètre le
fourbe et 7 mais c'est ça doit attendre
gagnant techniquement mais c'est clair
c'est moins clair que tout à l'heure
ouais mais il te sort une grosse défense
que si un jour il fait cavalier 4 qui
tenait un échec le pion h4d nul tu peux
vite te faire réseauter quoi tu peux
vite te faire réseauter et je suis pas
sûr que ce soit encore gagnant pour les
blancs même juste objectivement très
quoique annoncé c'est vrai mais je te
fais qu'avait lieu quatre là je veux toi
déjà
on élève en sueur mathieu justement à ce
matin et c'est un copain presse allait
peut-être ya pas fou prend 1,5 et orrin
hatch est en train de me dire ça puis on
prend tour à décarie des jeunes
paraissait imparable mais la foulée cinq
échecs épreuve 2 x 8 h 4 je pense pas
que tu prennes f2 je suis fait échec à h
4 direct c'est pareil il faut huit
équipes en f2 du g4 ça c'est plus c'est
plus fort le nom s'arrête nouveau pour
attendre kg 3 come on to be tôt 1 h cup
enfin bref de f4 ou est tu peux pas
jouer âge de 3 2 h 4 et touran de moi je
fus 8 en fait parce qu'il ya toujours
être faux match donc c'est plus hitler
après je vais pas faire f 4 80 euros en
r3 est ce que ces 500 devant mais le jeu
tourne b1
ok mais je veux que tu as part of au but
c'est quand même fou des trois fois oui
il faut une baisse ah non ça je pensais
d'ailleurs bref trois sociétés naroff en
cet échec auquel il peut faire un
cavalier de cacao requis par angers 4 il
fallait le mettre un cadre dans tous les
cas qui contrôle plus de case oui mais
il veut tout en face au garage
tu peux le faire dans tous les cas mais
c'est bizarre fois ci c'est deux
dirigeants c'est chaud chaud chaud et
sans infos et photos j'ai un très bon
deux fois sous voilà mal à ce jour la
pendule main aux caisses des pêcheurs au
rachat aura lieu 3 bien joué moi mais du
coup tu as peu de plus
tomber cette menace au 6 1 en une
recette des deux ânes ont fait chaque
d'abord à la finale est terrible à
l'horizon de temps ça sur la pendule
mauvais père est plus fort elle est
noire les noirs sont beaucoup plus forts
ces nouvelles partir très bon niveau
belle partie belle partie alors attends
qui on va choper on va choper béral ou
contre joseph michel st show mature
chiffres donc du coup ça joue seul ou
alain maxime mettre fi des maîtres
kebabier c'est la même chose des amis et
c'est la vérité crue ou cuite à tort
dans le tchat
puis-je avoir un lien
le lien on va te le mettre à les bim du
coup ça joue à naalin maxime c'est un
autre signe même s'ils ont aussi cinq
âmes un jour mais dans l'absolu ce n'est
pas si bête ce qu'au fond les noirs s'il
n'y a pas énormément aidé réfute mais
pas l'idée d'un jean dauger six mois je
crois que c'est un mode dirt allons bon
maintenant il est jeune donc il faut
prendre les 5 c'est toujours rigolo on
se pose avec une pièce en europe n'étant
qu'à ça sinon que logique ses juges et 5
à 4 c'est pas omettre mais ce mot
l'écran il est il est la couleur et -
ouais ça change de couleur quand on
bouge les caisses en réalisant un ok
c'est pour ça mais ça marche pas et quel
point je montre donc j'ai 5 à 4 c'est le
truc normal hein c'est là pour ça si
sauf qu'elle et ses quêtes vous prend
pions prendra aux alentours d 1 ou
défend hier qu'on peut continuer à
attaquer bon alors les gagner s'il ya
des gens qui écoutent le script en même
temps s'il vous plaît quand on commande
vos parties mettez sur mu et ouais je
veux faire juste ça s'appelle arenas
bitstream
ah ben c'est ça ouais bah arreter en
fait c'est parce que c'est en mode arena
en fait ces pistes rim à rennes
leukemans et ce soir dans huit heures
donc je crois que c'est à 20h30 21h à
quel arrivé le 3 en 8 heures à 20 heures
30 il y aura une arène chaise comme
arrêt net de madère quelle bêtise pas
mal avec l'idée de jeu qu'elle s'éclate
il en reprend du cheval wells a peut
être marqué ckd avec l'idée des soucis à
quel point très c'est joli ça et ça joue
pas mal quand même
ouais rayonner bas je peins pas pas plus
que ça je connais pas les gens donc je
peux pas être étonné moment de niveau
mais 1900 sur czech comme franchement ça
patine un peu un ok c'est ça joue ça
vous déjà vraiment pas mal ça fait
vraiment pas mal par contre la berra
loge voiture à perdre je pense qu'il est
2000 et qu'elle voire même peut-être
2100 en feed mais ne sait pas trop ce
qu'ils jouent un soutien de poids mais
perdent le flot de cadenas quand tu fais
une attaque anglaise
c'est dans la montée c'est l'unité
pareille date un appareil prend b2 quoi
qu'il en soit je pars là que même parfum
tu vas faire pas te faire caillou ne
peut-être fou prend ses quatre prix
c4eva lieu de l'ess prendre le foudroie
et tu veux que les deux carrés contre
les fous études basques au québec et en
france que non mais il veut mettre le
feu sur b2 mais ne le fut sommé de et
balancé f k taxes en une mais deux
camions comme venir danser quote ça fait
part à damas cinq noms wallonne c5 mais
bien joué ça va être long sous des
candidats dans le tampon ça va durer
quelques semaines encore un voire
quelques mois
ouais il faut il ya quatre ans prises
bref je pense quelque chose les prix
seront donnés mais peut-être du pion de
ce petit jeu je sais
3 sauver la colonne mais d'anglais avec
si les noirs et permettre le roi à
l'abri ils ont gagné assez facilement
ils devraient finir ses fossettes royal
d'un emprunt à 3 gars faut croire 4,6
toujours 24 et menacent donc d'un noeud
de 1 me laisse faire ce tronc tel point
qu'après ces 3 s'avère difficile parce
que les blancs ils n'ont pu que je ferai
jouer j 6 précède peut-être ce qui
pouvait pas le 5 au coude avant rien est
sûr cavaliers cinq jeux 6 et après je te
fais ce 3 est en fait le truc dans la
partie il a fait un peu la même idée
sauf que maintenant quand tu feras échec
stuff rica et béton on s'est un peu
moins malins ouais bon ça reste trop
d'ambition mais toujours défaut de 5 des
petits points intermédiaires ça peut
faire mal
ça reste écrasante chez écrasant - miles
c'est ton rock juste temps on se
développe pour ok je d'un qui font
recette
f5 et rock ouais mais bon il va pouvoir
faire f si l'on voit quand même je sais
pas s'ils savent très bien jouer encore
une fois il faut qu'on vous êtes mal
faut trouver du contrôle de cinq ont
fait qu'elle b3 on a besoin de guerriers
sans nous pour protéger notre royaume a
balancé f6 le fou ça pue un peu mais le
fou pour revenir sur la chine sans payer
toujours à trois ans de prison
irene idée peut-être tentés de fer
russes m6 puis on prend 4,5 le
championnat local puis on prend 1,7
je voulais faire ça ouais on quand les
fois autour d'un principe on est marin
on essayait de compliqué que ça peut
faire du bien ouais et peut-être qu'ils
avaient prises des catins plus des
quatre prises au 7 mai ouais on peut
voir qu'il ya quand même un peu c'est un
peu dangereux pour le noir mais ça ne
rime être mieux voiture avec laurent
avec les blancs tu te défends pas mal
était fait et un peu d'ouvrir bon ouais
c'est ça donc il ya jeu qui avait trop
avec un logo eia
les trois jolies donne une bonne partie
des noms comme roi il va faire quoi
française france 2 mots nous donne berne
c'est ça comme jerry une partie une fois
avec un clouage qui était resté pendant
longtemps avec un point b 2 j'ai bougé
le roi un moment donné j'avais pris la
dame et c'est la seule fut non à la tht
a plus trop de déracinement tabasse
quand il bouge le fouiller d'empreintes
moyens d'avoir une partie de nous une
banda jorf band of inspiré par le
meilleur d'entre nous alors on regarde
une partie un peu déséquilibré a
allez on regarde plus faibles il
s'appelle déséquilibré 300 points l'aude
et carla jusqu'à maintenant c'était des
joueurs qui avaient des lots à proches
alors on se refait l'ouverture une
berline aux royals ouais berlinois
hitchock sors de ce corps il a fait il a
pris la fédé 5 en 10 ou la non c'est
simple c'est logique que furent était en
fait après là ils perdent à prendre sur
les cases blanches l'habitat mcuh pour
arié c5
en fait il faut que les nombreux se
développe plus que d'écologie en fait
qu'ils ont fait mais sain comme si leur
adversaire faisait rien lorsqu'il se
dire un peu naïf cimpor après là je vois
pas de rechute
bah disons que en regardant le roi au
centre aussi longtemps il
d'après dangereux en fait c'est jouer
avec le feu ouais je vois pas de gains
prenant quand même arriver là si on
prend des quatre dom b3 on peut mettre
un truc quand des 56 qui est ce si ce
gip en somme je voyais pas la suite sur
une attaque du genre dam des sous dans
des cinémas jusqu'en des cinq peut-être
adam des cinq principes on n'aime pas
trop sur le cahier du gagnera sur ces
trois gains de temps mais concrètement
on attaque le cavalier donc dame en
question soit une dame dessin était
presque obligé de revenir sur des
maquettes fou de cette huile se prendre
comme ça et tu as vu il tend qashqai
cette prof parce que l'adolescent avait
défendu et sur barakat juste fou dès cet
été chouette tu veux jouer la finale
gran torino une dame de 5 ou de même
donne des chiffres fait très peur non
ouais c'est la même la même idée
tu peux même aller peut-être c7
d'ailleurs non c'est ce dont je reviens
au sein ne gagne plus de pions ouais ok
il est allé en b61 ça marche peut-être
oui mais alors attends cavaliers cinq
pions prend y aura peut-être des dames à
4 irene des cinq fonds de sauce mais tu
veux juste faire fut des six rock
histoire de à dessein quoi on est on est
combien je oui une fois ci aurait donc
du coup dans le d6 un peu d'un v6 l'idée
est bonne mais juste il fallait
contrôler la connaît pour empêcher des 5
il fallait voir ce que nos trains à
l'heure sa bulle fr et on l'avait pas vu
non plus du tout le cas là faut vraiment
fasse vite food et 6 rock mais je pense
qu'un bon coup pour les blancs s'appelle
faisait 5 des fonds peut donner un pion
pour cinq ans au coude avant dans ma
quête d'un bon coin et je faisais ça
pour montrer dans le filet ouais si les
gens prennent on peut prendre six ans je
sais pas dans quel ordre
mais juste pour montrer que sa qualifier
trois mêmes sont encore moins avec tous
les trous ou nascar.com séquelles et 5
arrive ça peut être des fonds peut de
nos actions pour ce genre d'initiative
ça peut être avantageusement sa ferme en
mai fu bu cette dame alphadas mcad c'est
quand même complètement logique hein je
garde ton point tu te garde le fou g5 à
et ses trois tours je le jouais avec les
noms il joue plutôt bien il a des bons
réflexes mai
un mail à ses côtés au roi s'est il
pense pas à ça son il pense pas à ça son
roi mais sinon c'est pas mal ce qui fait
la jeunesse il peut faire genre fut
décisif juste car l ie 5 3 et 8
ouais mais ça fait peur hein mais même
si c'est probablement le meilleur coup
ça peut faire peur en entrant ici je
pense ça serait une erreur parce que le
ca va avantager les noirs la finale de
la commission et de sous pression mais
je sais pas si coeur du maroc étant
celui de gagner contre tout aussi vrai
c'est pas faux et surtout on prend cette
dame c'est cette non on paye à l'option
food est ce que tu disais c'est ce 3e
set je veux juste dû bouger ma torrent
8,3 et cuissards qu'à la main et manque
de place à cette option
c'est vrai vanité mathieu s'alarme bien
poindre maintenant à beaucoup mieux
qu'avant
fodé silva sur le jackass 3 faut se
développer les rock et rock
[Musique]
quelle idée de aussi avec l'idée
lesquelles ces quatre jours mais qu'est
ce tu crois c'est logique faux pas de
défaut à rechercher simple le vainqueur
c'est la faiblesse
le fou se développe tranquille ou à
l'efb lensois gagnent toujours neuf mais
ils sont passés par une phase un peu
difficile pour je pense mathieu qu'il
est blanc oui oui oui parce que si
c'était une erreur
je mets un très petit cap a été puni et
mal autant quand même il faut qu'il
fasse sa fonction autant bas ils
représentent les maths avec un thé après
lui ou alors un prof de maths
voilà un prof de maths un taureau un
peuple
toronto un j'aime bien l'idée mais
pourquoi pas casser trop d'abord on est
sûr que le cavalier va lancer trois
jaunes etc ou une chine d'abord l'après
réfléchissez si vous autorisez 5 ou
moins d'options
ça sert à quoi la taca même temps deux
fois quand tu peut le manger direct par
à grand chose j'ai envie de te dire
donc on nous écrirons du château avec la
nva là tout lé bien d'arriver à paris
ok moi cela mahmoud savane confirme du
coup l'info est étroit donc il peut y
avoir un échange de vues sur le cas
quand l'option c'est donc défendant un
pion qui est en prise huit fois après ce
qu'il veut c'est jouer sur un clouage
peut-être même homme je vous sais sont
utiles mais je vois pas comment tu
arrives à le faire marcher bien loin des
aveux de deux bombes a été il faut
qu'ils aient change tout et qu'il fasse
pour s'éviter qu'il allait récupérer
sanctions quand même faut pas laisser
les envies trop longtemps battus eux ce
fut un mauvais gag s'appelle un marché
pratiquement donc voilà pour ces huit
pâtissier juste mais tu récupères
fonctions et aura une fille l'art est un
peu inférieure exactement faut 3
probablement dame sait si ces trois
dames sikasso en échange et met une tour
en c4 un temps c'est un signe ou pas
trop je sais que tu causes de fou prend
1,7
ouais j'aime bien pour les blancs ça va
être une souffrance en amont on va voir
on va voir si joueurs sont techniques
il a fait d'amis théâtre quoi c'est pas
bête de garder les dames d un fils un
bon réflexe
avec trois ans qu'il veut je vous sais
pas trop ce qu'il veut c'est être à 5 à
4 avec terreur pour fille s'est livré à
3 fait ce jeune patron
c'est un coup tu n'as pas vraiment de
loin sauf si le mec bronze la tour et
qui est bécotte qui marche ce qui est
peu ça arrive il a du rouge et toi alors
vu le temps est ce que t'as pas intérêt
à faire tout en 4g 4 essayer d'aller
crescendo attaque où l'attend la gate 1
c'est la guerre mais il a plus de vingt
secondes mat
un nom qui cela fait un peu dommage
généralement à ce niveau là mathieu
c'est rédhibitoire c'est un peu court au
cat ou qu'ils prient move to re cat way
il m'écoute et cruel
exprès un coup leur tour aux vins c'est
la crise
le torero 44.94 tour de essayez pas
jusqu'à nous il faut chercher leur
orbite mais tu vois quatre c4 aussi tu
peux plus mauvais de coûts c'est dur
c'est dur à civaux la peinture il a
utilisé 15 secondes après ils paniquent
souvent à madame prend 1 donne des deux
c'est trop dur match avec peu de temps
maintenant ou là mais ça va gagner
autant d'âmes des deux manches d'auto un
emploi il peut pas prêt le move et où
elle écoule effet d'un prince et 5 8 à
trois points 3 rebonds
bofa l'histoire ouais non il sait bien
il sait bien il s'est bien battu
alors on va essayer je prends dans
l'idée à particulier de commencer
peut-être plus dorée contre lequel j'ai
le droit
je connais la version kalach nom s'est
mise à genoux comme on peut le voir
exactement l'impression d'un accord
on a rit c'est la crise du temps d'en
claquer b3 c'est pas le meilleur coup
parce que le trou fait dans cette
ouverture c'est la case des cistes au
lac à ce dessein du courrier les farc et
bessin aux menaces et à aider si celles
ci font des six le plan ça va être un
jour de ramener ce qu'elle valait donc
fou g5 le meilleur au point gagné la
case est sain et ce qu'avaient les
faudra le remettre bien c42 sa dépense
énorme bombe et simple par an le 3 pour
aller sur la cas d'asthme et b3 c'est
pas un mauvais tour en soi mais le sait
quand même d'auto parce que là déjà il y
avait 1 4 qui a été ratée par la caf
j'ai le droit donc le meilleur coût pour
les blancs d'ailleurs c'était jouable à
plus de fougue et 5 s'est pas
complètement bête il faisait 3 5 par
exemple puis on comprend qu'elle va les
prendre
les rock et sacrifié en ce 3 il peut y
avoir raison ok ça c'est pas mauvais
quoi c'est théorique
oui oui face dans mon lit dans notre
livre avec les bilans
mais bon avec les noirs là il se
débrouille quand même très bien elle a
réussi à faire des cinq des quatre pôles
trois pièces 1 3 bons réflexes sont des
quatre c'est souvent le seul coup pour
perdre deux pièces mais là les noirs
sont contents ils ont réussi à combler
leur trou ou à elle mais j'ai la
majorité centrale nucléaire pour les
blancs c'est pas encore la fin du monde
le cavalier va venus en deux après il
faudra le top ça arrive et de contrôler
les cases blanches chez certains et du
un genre les normands de faire s'il faut
7 7 5 6 4
ça n'a rien mis au point mais bon on
peut je suis parti pris j'aime bien
cette ouverture
en tout cas il fait plaisir la caf j'ai
le droit sacrifier une pièce ça crée une
pièce et j'ai gagné alors que j'avais
juste deux pions contre la pièce le
torture 50 tu as ça gagnent des parts
icc content là dans le chatt mathieu
c'est bien celle-là c'est ce qu'il faut
voir 60 joueurs c'est un montant que
wayne gens qui arrivent donc une copie
que c'est aussi dans le cours de chasse
explain sur les flèches nikov gratuit
sur chasse et bâle ok mais tout ce qui
est gratuit je me méfie ouais mais fish
gratuit non non c'est bon il paraît
qu'ils font des trucs pas mal
il voulait que je fasse un truc mais
finalement ils m'ont j'ai plus une
nouvelle et avait proposé de faire
quelque chose mais toujours la règle aux
intel tout le monde veut façon à donner
je n'ai jamais refait tu crois que tu
viennes au studio un jour pour la faire
quand c'est gratuit c'est toi le produit
exact raté gicm en cavalier à 4 pourra
casser 5 mais juste tactiquement on n'y
croit pas lorsque je veux dire tant de
couples sont jolies mais tu vas un peu
c'est un peu du mauvais côté de
l'échiquier je peux essayer de voir
revenir comme ça mais je vois pas ma
chute je cherche qu'à et 17 - qu'elles
font le coup de canon 6 prix aussi c'est
vrai tu peux faire tes à 4h france inter
va pas se faire instaurer un camion
notre shooteur notre rôle c'est sacré a
vraiment laissé sa gouaille a pas de
damas cinq parce qu'on avait quatre
toujours époque nous regarder ces
déchets qui ont fait qu'ali c'est simple
mais ça marche pas le cas et c'est ça
qu'il faut sept
ouais c'est lui dispenser le problème
mais on peut avoir une idée alors qu'à
et détroit ces 5 h a-15 auquel l'epl sur
l'attaqué avec ses 5 seul coup on peut
le manger
je voulais montrer les blancs des fans
peuvent the sec 4 après que querrien pas
dans l'absolu genre comme ça pour
bloquer lequel les trois se trouve le
bloqueur un peu un cavalier brune seul
tu en décidant détroit et puis on prend
on fait qu'elle les prend et on prend
sept remplaçants qui les prend
maintenant dans la case des saints et ça
ça peut commencer à un malade mental
sont pas les bloquer ces cinq bien joué
bien joué fu h 4 ont fait g3 donc c'est
bien pour nous en donne après ça peut
être une idée point noir un petit coup
de fouet à ascot jeu 3 je repars en un
set je vais pas partir la voulais gagner
un temps effet rab 5
mais oui mais je peux aussi peut-être
faire ça en premier ouais mais oui que
my wife 5 5 7 ans
mais oui ça c'est pas bête non à ce
projet de fêtards a5b catane c'est cette
brave dame à 5 un peu naïf web etc
pourquoi ça serait un mauvais coup au
lait blanc pas trop de raisons mais
sûrement il n'a pas vu mes 4 way marques
comme aurait dit je peux avoir le gain
du tournoi
alors on peut te mettre un peu le maître
tac marquant qui va venir faire faillite
des jeunes sûrement avant pour arriver
en pleine forme
par contre je protège leur sueur sinon
je vais gueuler il faut pas qu'ils
sortent les nouveautés pour la red
alors c'est toi qui sort les nouveautés
sur les parties pédagogique wen s'est
pas des grosses grosses chine
jeune ballet mire mais movaizhaleine qui
était pas mal qu'est le ac prend des
trois là j'avoue que j'étais assez bon
temps non sans voix tant voit quand même
à des gros trucs fous au 6 octobre
c'est qu'un petit avantage noir un bail
que je suis moins sûr quand il faut et
six pouces et quatre non ouais et alors
je veux faire quoi reconnaître aussi pas
une mince affaire fouet cette nouvelle
option b est-ce que je peux jouer les
quatre faut aussi sa flotte adaptée à ce
qu mais des petits poutine dans le chat
à l'udac phf 4 franchement pourquoi on
aime on est un roman de banane on
parvient en d2d des nouvelles du front
aux attaques ph parce que perdre filet
sur le front il en russie c'est un nom
il est docteur martin doc là bas il
attend qu'on geslin s'il faut aller au
boulot et le boulot mais il fait une
pause et c'est pour ça que ce premier de
basset a commencé d'habitude à midi donc
c'était pour garder une certaine âme
c'est logique c'est pas bête pour ça
peut faire une pause pour ceux qui
travaillent et puis après je sais
qu'avec le télétravail en ce moment est
un acquis qu'on est ma grosse loose
[Musique]
julienc est en tête avec joseph joseph
l'avez vous fait bonne impression
d'ailleurs les deux ont fait bonne
impression qu un sens on va voir quand
ils se rencontrent fera pas rater la
partie faudra pas les rater quand ils se
rencontrent il ya gfk il faut reprendre
bah on va peut-être a besoin de toi
contre le pérou 1 si jamais été dans le
coin tu balances et je sais pas quand on
joue contre le pérou
internet m'a regardé ça c'est une date
je crois que le jour j il ya un c'est ça
mais je crois qu'il m'a écrit pour me
dire qu'il y avait il avait besoin des
deux pour un match qu'on ne sait plus
quel pays
moi je vais me coucher en verre de trop
c'est que le soir je me couche tous par
leur demain on vous contre l'azerbaïdjan
en championnat d'europe mais est-ce que
c'est intéressant ça c'est que les
blancs sont bien ouais non les gens sont
chauds ans les gens disent ouais
pourquoi les grands maîtres viennent pas
nous aider tout je leur ai dit d'aller
casser quand même pas évident tu vois
plutôt les sages à 9h30 mondiale et
après je me couche pas si tôt mais je
suis je suis morte ou est ce qu'on peut
trouver le lien mais demain demain 17h
un mercenariat bonne idée prend je
voulais faire 5 dames 1 mais l'ol jack
qui prend aussi les blancs sont un peu
mieux damas deux dames c4 nous donne un
demain 5
demain deux jeunes bien les prs les
profs en fait à l'aise face aux élèves
qui font les cons sur l'arcade pendant
les cours en téléconférence à ça va être
spécial sauf si les cours en
téléconférence a je pense qu'il y aura
des best-of après s'être fait très
clairement oui c'est vrai les blancs
sont mieux la même foi ou leur a
peut-être fait un peu optimiste mais est
ce qu'il n'ya pas d' imbéciles qui est
cinq dames prend des quatre secondes des
cats
alors ça aussi situé à sacrifier la
kalach il faut pas réfléchir cette
seconde derrière la dalle b6 d'honneur
mais voyez dès qu'on pense en tous les
cas d'hommes c4 et c5 ou d'un des deux
c'est bien ma vie par rapport à la
pendule qui la plus dorée c'est pas mal
joué un ouais les cavaliers afin de
forger de moi j'irai 1 h 8 pour inviter
des fourchettes en ainsi taclé ses cinq
tels taux la plume doré donc
bon ça gagne pas encore il ya dame b si
on est clos et caisses par ajout a bien
joué ça je pense voilà me donne ces
trois appareils en même temps prendre
mais qu'as tu as tu fait des échecs tu
m'étonnes ses trois échecs en g3 et je
juge de fond qui ont beaucoup aux
caisses est mieux jouer mais il faut
près mme blum et les coûts comme à froid
est très bien joué voilà c'est la joie à
la souris ouache de vitamine b3 d'un
maire trois faux premier vote de faux
primove est de 9,3 tête d'une c4 mais là
ils prennent ou pas qui a été sept bien
joué parce que damas et six dans le
secteur auprès de mauvais deux coups il
va tomber très bas mais aussi avec le
froid on les lots c'était pas mal gré
dans sa lutte chaque ace est donc bien
joué la dame d'apcher trois échecs je
pense tenir avec les vins étaient encore
mieux à te dire qu'elles sont autres
gagnants m 85
[Musique]
après tours b 8 jeux peuvent eux ces
trois noms sur ces huit jeux peuvent eux
qu'est bessin groupe donc aimé ça que je
peux perdre en se méfiant sais que tu es
bien maintenant cavalier jeu polémique
en italie à l'est où j'ai eu deux
quintaux triste bref cette f4 je vais
mettre seulement taureau en d3 je
pensais peut-être juste un fait nul en
fait ouais vas faire mieux ouais mais
ils font des bonnes parties tu vois on
rigole on rigole mais tour des huit jeux
pompage peugeot perd 1 5 qui m'a
complètement bluffé je faisais tout
reprendre et 4 octobre et 8 je crois que
tu avais je tort suite
ok donc ça c'est joseph joue contre un
de meilleurs lots ouais c'est parti très
importante ce qui joue contre harare
oliver ce que c'est un fan de la série 1
re avec oliver oui je pense et du coup
il lui a joué une année qu'il avait qu'a
réalisé 8 donc c'est pas inhaler keane
et à 6 jamais de te liens non mais après
il est dans troll pas trop juger
ils appellent ça la variante de brooklyn
sur sur le site
c'est un peu de la mer en fait ouais
après les très sexy même passion qui
socialement bien qu mais j'aime pas trop
- cette approche de en guise de jaunay
n'importe pas mon approche du jeu
d'échec parce que tu apprends rien je
lui fais oui mais je peins un autre
comment aussi d'ailleurs mais j'aime
bien apprendre des choses donc à prêter
venir jeter alex avait montré ce que
j'avais juste sur la troupe au ski il ya
trop et en partie non mais moi je le
fais contre un champion du monde après
mais j'ai cassé c'est pas avantage voir
si j'ai quatre c'est plus 150 c'est
moins 50 déjà sur leur vie après j'ai
quatre hockey qui avale et f1 qu'alléger
trois projets 5
il ya moyen de l'unc et blanc car ils
disent qu'il a inscrits depuis dix jours
à oliver c'est vrai qu'il ya quelques
quelques soucis sur ce tournoi sur la
présence de deux personnes qui jouent
pas forcément seul on va dire ça comme
ça
ah ok et cavaliers f1 mais bon pour le
mans sur ce convoi nous en tout cas sur
les parties qu'on a commenté c'était
comme à l'open lui mais ça a toujours
été des parties humaine un essai 4 bien
joué pourquoi elle est en f1 quand on
peut les tours seuls huit logique donc
je fonce faut sortir le fou très bien
joué on met notre cavalier en d2 mais
après un début de partie un peu
difficile de joseph qui lâchent les
lémuriens je ne me joue bien
stratégiquement joseph
il y avait aussi faux airs 4 qui posait
une question était à prendre ici sans
menace ce que rock en fait le noir ils
doivent le faire mais est ce qu'ils ont
vraiment envie avec se tient chaque
doigt la forme du couffo g5 intégrée du
coup un bon coup c'est le même effet on
y envoie un coup un peu mieux
non j'aime bien j'aime bien la prob la
performance des blancs bien après une
tête qu'il faut qu'ils jouent simplement
avec f3 et rock
moi je fais trois tours en f3 tu as
breton alan roch tour à la f3 ouais en
fait des cinq épaves hand made man
aspire à priser quelques 30 ouais et je
te vis non justement le bessin enfin
probablement d'un coup il y avait cinq
reprises et j'attaque la fsa et je fais
3 et caisse assez logique mais en allant
de le bouger tellement envie de le
dessin je vous ferez mieux 3 d'abord a
du sens mais jours ok les blancs d'oeufs
de cabillaud 3 f30 ou f3 tout de suite
tour à la main tu as raison c'est un bon
cru je vais bien développer toutes mes
pièces quoi ouais nan franchement match
j'ai envie de te dire on voit de la
qualité aujourd'hui pour l'instant sofa
soldes
franchement les gens les gens jouent
vraiment bien et ça fait d'être un tempo
fougeux 3 donc l'idée c'est que soit la
prison à prison des six est ce que tu
penses mathieu qu'avec toutes les vidéos
qui sont fait à présent en français ça
fait un petit peu augmenté le niveau
général des joueurs sur internet
en tout cas ce que tu penses que les
joueurs qui suivent votre iphone je
m'étais pas posé la question mais savent
ça paraîtrait logique ce que j'ai dans
le dessin tu n'as pas trop envie de
jouer mais c'est peut-être un bon coup
mais parce que cavalia cette étude fut 4
kelly des singles ça j'ai hurlé
s'inquiète pas trop je comprends pas
l'idée qui a allaité 5g pas je n'ai pas
compris mais là vieux 4 maintenant le
cap pour attaquer des six mais il amène
quelque chose dans un 5 mai rue main je
peux prendre et 4
non mais je le demande c'est à force de
faire des vidéos et tu vois qualitative
avec toi avec fab avec vlad et tout ça
les gens ils regardent quand même
beaucoup faire les gens qui sont ici
regarde t aime beaucoup les strips en
général donc les gens qui jouent le
tournoi regarde français dont beaucoup
l'esprit mais je me demande si le fanny
beau mais quand même mieux que qu'il ya
quelques années je te jure je vois
maintenant oui enfin je suis d'accord
enfin ses mains c'est logique quand on
travaille et quand on fait des échecs en
province les gars sont vraiment fareins
et 5 africa dans la boum ça comment
cette même fosse 1 4 4 ça commence à te
regardes tu ouvres les lignes sur le roi
il ya des jeux pions f4 tempo et salua
monsieur pessoa qui salue kevin salut
mathieu comment ça pulse avec tout ça ça
pulse parade quoi comment ça se passe
pour toi
il est prof monsieur pessoa donc à mon
avis il est en train de donner ce que
ces faits soient qui souffrent ces
chèques et je sais pas faut lui demander
mais ça m'étonnerait nom et 2.3 été
pendant que logique mais il veut mettre
la tôt où ça a du sens aussi le principe
sockeye des cinq ans à la caserne 7 et
mieux contrôler sans que les noirs que
je joue quand même pas mal ils défendent
à reims saint jovite non grève ça joue
bien ça joue vite ça joue bien
franchement j'aimerais pas l'étape et
bien ils vont pas l'air ils n'ont pas
l'air d'être comme un drap arriver à
enlever une pièce défense mais ce qui
est des sons en fait c'est c'est un
bouquet vélib en fait qui nous embête un
peu convaincant et qui réalise un kafka
tome mais bon le truc c'est que c'est
dommage ça se marierait bien avec ça va
pas trop mais orson welles en karting à
ce jour non c'est non mais oui un moyen
dans ma tête je lui enlever sa part des
deux bateaux mais c'est vrai que c'est
pas si bête faut prendre des 6 à 1 sur 8
2 m 3 ou d'un f2 pour prenant des cats
après fait plus précis vrai on va voir
ce qu'ils jouent mais sa valeur prise f6
prise f6 prises ces trois serein ouais
c'est peut-être dire jouer qu'ils feront
à chaque prise non non je voulais je te
prend 1,7 à près d'alger catéchètes
marché vous bon il a repris en c3 donc
ouais c'est très bien joué il ya un
petit souci je ne pas bête du monde
après on n'a pas trop de menaces pèsent
tour f 5 un jour les mêmes prises en 900
g iii maintenant qu'elle est franchie en
date un coup wen an qui doit je sache
c'est le nom qu'a prise il y avait 56
ans prise
d'ailleurs il faut prendre les 6e pense
sont des huit taureaux et chevaux d'un
grand dessein quand je peins à prendre
mes seins qu'elle mangeait les pions et
après tu rebondis verges et cinq ans
plus tard dame g5 faut être quatre le
roi peut se retrouver pris dans des
courants d'air qu'il faut pas oublier
que le roi répond g8 a dû déranger 6,7
je pense bien joué five cache sous ce
nom mais les blancs mais pas moi même si
ça fouette cadarache
il faut l'appliquer à des machines tu
fais quand même sacrément la gueule je
pensais juste gagnant pour les ans parce
que terme assises d'alger sila les
visages de syfy
non on réfute aurait aussi s'il veut
faire mais je vois pas bien ce phénomène
abba temps là les deux ils ont vraiment
bien joué et 6 échecs du fou de cinq
dames 1
suisse s'attend déjà coupé un roi prend
24 dames f4 et attend prend bien mais je
rate beaucoup de trucs aujourd'hui web
bandama schwyz était trop vu leur jeu
pour le gain pascal 1,26 me tieleman à 3
et 4 tab en adaptant ses tapas fou j'ai
trois pour reconduire il ya tour avec un
matt serra le 4 way à plus long terme en
année cité comme cha ce point comme ont
énormément de l'affluence sur
l'augmentation du niveau c'est beaucoup
plus facile de jouer aujourd'hui qu'il
ya 10 ou 20 ans nous dit jean d'hyrule
c'est ce que je pense un quand tu
comptes additionne un peu tout soit plus
facile de faire des partis laïques
d'affaires brut 3 merdé droit roi par le
web 2 mais tour à 1 il a maintenant pour
à 1 gagner inf'ogm qu'un joueur roger 4
pts 2 dams et 8 échecs
maintenant il y avait d'un processus
normal j'ai parfois 1 300 oui mais moi
j'ai trois dames g8 trois points
l'aléatoire frma tu exprimes toi -
grosse partie franchement ça joue pas
mal un voile et ça joue bien les gars
dont le chat ou quoi faut pas me dire
que ça gruge ou quoi parce que là les
parties convoi s'est départi très normal
il ya des erreurs des deux côtés s'est
pas départi parfaite 1 mathieu tu
confirmes ou là alors son os à
comprendre plus logique à chercher
compliqué donc là on transporte dans une
c'est pas du touring lund je sais ce que
c'est l'ouverture de ces 1 4 5
c'est une écossaise ouais capitalisme
d'état il est con le truc pour le nom
des joueurs ça à temps et bien je me
disais que sur tmc 8,3 g3 et peut-être
d'un match 3 maths qui était raté un
même où celui-ci je faisais juste new
wave est un processus du goût acide
matin il a maintenant un peu raté le
match
je croirais un dessin vaut mieux je
foulais 4 devant parce que l'être on
peut être un peu moins bien pris et ruiz
genre foulée 5
il joue une petite finale un fou des
êtres tam eu deux balles de set
ouais je prend 1,17 ou tu dois prendre
du roi et je fais flotteront et plus de
finale quoi grand roque est il à tetris
prises et fourbe et 5 justement un petit
blind earth
il a bien écouté ces nouvelles adresses
qui l'a pas écouté et il a sûrement
trouvé lui-même apithy browsers c'est
quand même ça joue sajou à savoir au
classement 1 comment ça marche au
tournoi 82 je en suis pas un saint
joseph michel qui est toujours leader
mais qui a perdu le strict parce que
quand tu gagnes trois parties d'affilée
tutu marque plus de points après tu
marques le double de points mais est ce
que marco les mieux notés et marcamps
rêve est calme il a commencé plus tard
il est forcément plus bas important il a
peut-être amis sombre épisode où il a
peut-être palisson réponse non plus été
très con de dire que tu joues avec un
solo dansé glas autant jouer avec son
bruit pseudo les jeunes amis vous
souhaitez vous souhaitez préparer ces
personnes que ton pseudo
oui mais dans ces cas-là dis pas que tu
vires grille dis pas qu'il est oui vous
voyez vous la voir le lien après un jeu
de tête juste pour voir les parcelles
jeune je me fous des sept
ouais mais d'un mode deux fois aux 7
pourquoi ce serait si fort cha la capote
masqué qui a battu un joueur à 1800
lorqu'il et 1050 ou là et bien à toi il
donne son pseudo marquants du coup il te
dit audika caylar oliver a c'était lui
qui avait pas match retard bah c'est lui
la partie qu'on a vu où il à celui de
gagner avec les kings et g8 ouais ok bon
- il joue pas de prépa mais il aurait pu
se prendre un matin m il y avait damage
from hathaway
c'était chaud c'était chaud ouais donc
bien jouer d'un mois deux échecs un oui
et donc il fallait sans doute je fawcett
mais elle a gagné le pion on ne s'est
pas fait tu prends tu fais grand roque
et tu joue encore avec les normes sur
mais bon on sait c'est un pion commencé
la partie avec un point de plus je mets
le fou ou trois je mets une torrents d
un jeu peut mettre mon rang et de france
f1 - davantage c'est clair mais après ce
que je dis toujours aux joueurs dans le
chat aux auditeurs tu as et qu'ils se
découragent rapidement quand ils ont
perdu du matériel mais moi quand
j'oublie souvent je leur montre que même
contraint même contre un joueur même
contre un grand maître tu joues avec les
noirs bien sûr le hockey c'était moins
bien tu es certainement tu vas perdre
mais c'est par une position qui
s'abandonne encore je pense qu'il faut
c'est être compliqué aux fds il faut pas
faire ce faux pas échangé trop pièces
dans le jour d'autres faits québécismes
pour remettre la structure un peu mieux
alors ça ça peut être dangereux mais
c'est la tendance et 5 et b6 roi vsat
calme ouais c'est sain qu'il veut faire
fourbe et 6 mai tour huit taureaux
sainte non tour d un nom le four revient
sur trois il a qu'a mangé un deuxième
plan il faut essayer de l'enfermer avec
ces simples mais je crois que ça allait
pour les hawks et les ajustements très
poussées comme c'est simple c'est
vraiment très pratique puisque ça
bonjour à tous je souhaite que ma femme
et je pense qu'il faut bechis avec lui
des tours 8
jean roy et font notre simple c'est pas
mal parce que c'est qatar est on prend
des cinq mais je peux je tourne bien et
je vois pas bien j'ai l'impression qu'on
n'a pas juste mais du coup et c'était
pas mal de souffrances prennent un peu
prématuré mais oui c'est dans le seul
c'est une erreur alors on peut regarder
maurice better qu'on trouvera balle et
ça a l'air d'être une quarantaine de
langues des changes qu'on a beaucoup vu
sur la chaîne
des cas d'indicés 3 ici c'est une erreur
le cavalier n'appartient pas à cette
case que quand il ya tuant ses quatre en
fait il le cavalier mieux en d2 pour
aller se ressent un lien à 23 soit les
anges et trois séquences et 3,26 tu
regardes bien il va être obligé d'aller
à eux deux un jour où la 1/3 1/3 bekkat
ça appartient pas trop à la poste mary
oublieras pour nadja buts à 1
oui on tient là les normes ont bien un
jeu de stratégie nous ment je connais
beaucoup de tours services web 11 vaut
mieux mettre les tours la dame malade je
bougeais met à tour d'abord tout cas ils
suivent il suit bien les carlingues
il saisit à bien les carreaux kahn qu'on
a qu'on a appris jusqu'à maintenant ça
fait plaisir tu as more is better qui a
vraiment joué comme comme on l'a vu sur
l'estrie il a bien appris le truc mais
je suis sûr que devoir de bien revoir
les schémas et bien les répéter ça te
fait gagner 200 300 points elo à ce
niveau bien sûr d'avoir les bons après
il faut quand il a travaillé sa tactique
à côté etc
on en a besoin mais ça ne facilite pas
la partie quand tu sais ce que tu fais
parce que là il a joué juste les coûts
logique qu'on a vu l'un kenzo peut-être
changer de parti je dois aller les
gaffes une pièce malheureusement et ça
va nous permettre de voir à la tiens on
peut voir mon gré follet contre von
bergen attaquant c'est intéressant tu
les connais un bon bordeaux des coups
moi je sais qui c'est toi tu sais qui
c'est mon regret fu lei je vois souvent
souvent sur le chat exemples de joueurs
à 2004 c'est ok donc d'un os est
intéressant l'autre poussé à 5 e joué
par guy rey dans le tournoi contre ding
aylagas faire je sais pas qui mais
échoue il y en a qui me révolte qui lui
dit c'est faux la mode et soleil il le
dit c'est pas moi c'est vrai que c'est
le le pseudo ressemble quand même oui
c'est vraiment pas toi d'une douleur
mais j'ai du mal à le croire c'est un
personnage d'harry potter
ouais je crois un prof nous je crois je
crois assez vraiment pas lui et ses
parents c'est marrant mais plutôt on te
croire à l'essec et l'autre il ya une
majuscule en f1 au web c'est pas tout à
fait le même pseudo est-ce que fouet 4
si ça peut être intéressant
georges je garde mon fou et je te fais
un truc
système de londres c'est probablement
pas mal mais bon dans l'absolu tu veux
jouer contre le faux de cases blanches
dans quelles sont les fautes maintenant
c'est pas si bête mais ailleurs c'est ce
genre d'idée la juge juste pour savoir
un jeu le monde pour moi est ce que
genre ça c'est idiot j'aurais essayé de
faire ça non mais de trois et peut
peut-être jeu simple oui oui non c'était
je veux juste je te demander pour la
structure mais là ce qu'il a fait c'est
bien le blanc sont un peu mieux sans
risque ah ya passé s'il est sûre ce sens
parce que j'allais dire mais il est
quand même mais dans l'absolu c'est
mieux d'aller en e2 puisque tu as des 5
des fois c'est 5 e les 5 m
il y avait aussi eu trois qui pouvait
pas empêcher la menace pandémique est
mieux dans la porte à un petit à petit
mais tu dois commencer à jouer des bons
points mais je fais retour et des 5
il veut reprendre le cavalier pour
empêcher fou 17 il faut grands noms mais
ça c'est j'ai gagné talent de parti
comme ça avec les gens mais pour les
bons ans le 2 pas avoir cavaliers f1
donc là intéressant qu'est f5 pour
donner une petit avantage en finale ou
qu'ils aient bessin il veut jouer au
caïd et 6 et 5
mais tu ne te rends à c'est quand même
un bon avantage blanc mais c'est pas la
fin du monde
narrow vient de mettre plus 5 sur 20
vite ce compte n'est pas choquant même
un même s'il n'est pas aux joues pas à
100% et c'est assez chaud du co2 est
fatigué oui mais ces belles perfs un jeu
rage eux qui décident d'abord toi c'est
un peu naïf mais bon il tenait encore
cahier des 6 ou même dame c'est trop
dame b 2 arte or c'est lui le fera sur
gaffe à pas se prendre un bon dessin
mais tu encore qu'à et des 6es du baggy
mme bessette
oui les cas mieux puisque quatre parfois
ça peut être une idée d'abord baisse
c'est pour ça que la catalane à ce
niveau là souvent femmes à beaucoup de
niveaux c'est game assez chiant parce
que quand tu joues sans contre je sais
déprimante emprise est prise baisse est
à moins qu'ils aient trouvé huit ya pas
tomber 8la jeu
trouver 8 et les 6,1 kg 6 loto rang des
huit qui vient et george ii alors ça ne
marche pas bien mais voilà je pense que
tu es sur la rigueur de 113
il va reprendre dans les sprints info
m51 on a des regrets hathaway mais il
est sous contrôle la même si on sait lui
cinq minutes c'est du samu du thouet
séduit 3 je ne prenais pas pourquoi que
les jauges aussi vite ce moi qui suis
cool mais peut-être si tu t'arraches ça
qui a envoyé wave 3 en séance à calmer
les ardeurs
ok menace ni chipeau mais bon ça peut
être pas bête pour regagner la colonne
juste barrage cinq matches 4 un peu
bizarre mais d'accord 8
faire à quatre peut-être oui c'est
l'idée mais bon à quatre c'est pas matin
[Musique]
moi ça va on reçoit at war iii ses gains
mais oui je l'aurais pas fait presqu'à
deux gros cube plus et à jauger capteur
offre ses deux gros qui ont de plus mais
un torrent des trois médecins qui le
voudront bien ouais pour le moment il se
passe rien en contrôle quand même un
ouais mais dans l'absolu c'est si tu
veut le défendre mais qui a valu un des
cats et douloureux avec les noirs je
trouve qu'ils risquent de le trick m
mais bon bien sûr c'est un ami des deux
tu vois déjà la d2 c'est chiant non tu
perds tu perdais mes trois thèmes d'un
des deux tours henri iii non j'ai très
faim là on imagine juste et surtout tu
as l'air d'avoir à vous madame ça passe
et c'est dommage qu'ils soient repartis
ok là il a bien joué avec les bons ils
haïssent et bien il sait bien ré agencé
pour 5
je ferai un petit coup d'oeil 4 h 5 donc
autant mais peut-être les yeux la case
d3 quand tu fais toi seul puisqu'il a
peut être envie peut-être de l'onu il ya
un peu chier qui ouais j'aurais fait h4
vous il est un peu chez qui chez qui est
dit et qui il verrait team trop tout
contrôler bah enfin il bouche aux
cavaliers vont revenir vers des 5
mais en fait on sait qu'elle a souvent
quand on a des filles plus les pièces
adverse bon sur les ailes dames lors la
lune tourne à 8,9 en mai 4 en france 2
souvent ça se gagne à leroy dont les
pièces adverses sont passés de l'autre
côté h 4 h 5 ça nous d'attaquer un bon
là dans le cas précis à temps
3 c'est ce qui fait maintenant 1,5 d'un
fou mais attend il n'y a pas de problème
à travers ses reprises sur échec en dame
saint homme ccdh siens sain il faut pas
s'attendre à ses formes on est mieux
mais c'est vrai c'est un peu con con
d'avoir donné ce nom
il a bien progressé qu'avec les blancs
quoi qu'il en soit tu auras un torrent
tu vas où attendaient au coude avant ils
n'apparaîtront un qui était plus fort ah
non parce que tout prend 1,3 me n'ont
été possible parce que la maintenance au
menu ce torrent au point 3 c'était que
je faisais cavaliers prend cette attaque
mais j'ai déjà écrit b3 et gère 130 b3
ça soulage largement les noirs un bien
et je sais 5 mais ça a l'air de pas
marché ah et je veux gagner à vii as a
souffert mais parce que contre ogeu sur
le roi qui est six taureaux 8 monde donc
ça c'est très bien je blaguais parce
qu'il n'ya pas de pensée quatre vingts
seimat
en plus de perdre la dame n'doye
peut-être faire rage suite
mais canal et m6 doit gagner oui t'as
quoi d'autre de toute façon tu es noir
mince et ça va pas se mentir ça pue
mais bon tout recettes cela peut-être ne
coule plus logique que tu tentative y
est surtout ruitz prise prise roi
apprend qu'elle est sur un terrain
français cap qui protège tous du coup
c'est le sait pas vraiment eu un piège
dont g 8 qui avait les mêmes s'ils
s'avèrent fort que tu étais tu vas faire
d'albert mon âge 2 et damas mais fédérer
2 cela ce temps ni d'impôt mais
on était plutôt bonne partie des blancs
mais un peu chez qui grince était
complètement gagné mais c'est bien joué
du coup fallait faire dams et 3
probablement pour la ministre il pouvait
parler plus de défensea enfants leur dit
ce qu'il dit et ce qu'il défend encore
un peu non
non maintenant huit cas m6 règne à
l'univers
y a qu'à voir ça jusqu'au bout tente un
dernier piège surnager de foule 4 et là
il y en a plus c'est bien gagner mais ce
que ça les met en tête
non non pas du tout en fait victime qui
m cadets on l'a pas vu donc on regarde
bien les payeurs ray et dans les
premiers faux pas il faut qu'on trouve
attend fkd peut pas faire une recherche
que la vie si cela se passe mal les
points f2c fini n'en a gagné que c'est
juste ma tin ont facilité un corps de
masse m cadets mkd mkd la société h3 kf2
et d'un match en maths j'ai fait à quel
point de trois guinéens des maths c'est
lorsque guillaume pâte en attendant on
devrait endurer trop m cadets mathieu
bauer aux sharks à lille dont tu peux
mais je voulais voir je voulais essayer
de trouver comme ça mais je peux faire
une recherche clavier et on va voir
contre qui joue lui la gagne et déjà on
va les regarder civile a gagné sa partie
j'aimerais apprendre
il a pris mon cadet il a les noirs
contre berra lors d'un vote sans argent
ah non j'ai cru qu'il avait garée bien
et [ __ ] mais pas du tout c'est quoi
une sicilienne
ces vues bien bizarre dit mme call of
c'est une kalach les prieurs 6 berra
l'autre joue par un quelconque où se
donnent trois de cinq jours où l'on
donne la qualité parce que le cavalier
va être enfermé bientôt revenir merci
pour les arenas a occupé avec où je
l'espère bien
bien sûr on peut participer
et oui en des soins la chaîne en anglais
et sur la chaîne en anglais
pourtant non ils auraient cousu
nouvelles il aurait pu nous mettre sur
la chaîne en anglais et éventuellement
missive leinders qu'ils étaient contents
sa partie un petit fourchette donc le
leader en difficulté le bruit le
coleader en difficulté et ça va laisser
un boulevard à joseph cua ou michel mais
quoique ce pas fait encore il a les
cavaliers il arrivait encore des
innovations si on n'a pas vu dino lyon
l'a pas vu on va déjà voir s'il a quatre
à cinq qui veut jouer à 4 cherchons le
contre-feu c'est par elle joue et c'est
même bien joué après bank 1 comme ses
trois refroidir ça risque de le
refroidir il reste combien de temps il
reste 25 minutes vous qu'est-ce
conseillerais caniveau minimum pour lire
ou utiliser le livre dégainer la kalach
il est dur quand même mathieu il est
moins dur car à l'origine arabe aux
intel est allé très fort voilà au ritz
et avec food et 5 à quel point ceux de
thenon nom qui marche pas je me rendrai
de tnk bp capitaux qui avait 403 non
dans le se trouve sur la seule logique
cette baie saint qui fait des tentes et
un vous le niveau
honnêtement sur ces femmes non non il
était passé du rang et du nid bits donc
là et qu'il est plus facile
voilà qui avait quatre salaires bassam
nation c'est ça
on peut retourner les jeudis 10 cas pas
les dames des 8es pour faire très vite
n'ont peut-être pas non au tour des deux
je pense que les blancs sont encore sous
contrôle pour désosser un bon coup tu
défends a cassé deux temps pech mary 2
tu défends f2 et c33 faiblesse que tu as
dans ton camp après il va il faut que
les blancs commencent à jouer les coups
un peu plus actif alors à bouger la dame
n'a 6 7 3 et chasser les plus noires 3d
reste que tu fais des stages par
internet en ce moment d'entraînement ce
que oui j'ai beaucoup de boulot avec le
confinement il m'a dit encore pire
qu'avant il fait des stages photo lutte
que les gens viennent chez lui pour
faire des stages de préparation les
stages de pré pas sur internet
ouais non je donne des cours mais j'aime
avec le candidat je pensais pas avoir
besoin d'en rajouter
mais là je vais recommencer en donner un
j'ai donné un cours hier dans l'es22 -10
que t'as pas l'impression que c'est plus
difficile en terme de motivation de 1,6
français oui mais en plus on n'a pas des
chances dans la vie il faut trouver que
c'était plus facile de d'avancé quand à
une échéance que ce soit dans une vie
amoureuse pour un boulot aux études et
ce qui t'attend à 7 300 fermes locales
et gens là travaillent et les échecs ne
serait-ce que bosser pour moi sachant
que j'ai pas de tournai ont vu ça me
déprime
ouais mais moi aussi je trouve que c'est
difficile de travailler quand t'as pas
de après les choses père mais bon faut
je me remotive là demain j'ai deux
courses sauvages
mais bon cela devient tellement rien à
[ __ ] en fait c'est extraordinaire
c'est beaucoup moins et blanc l'ont
gagnée ouais ça fait ça même mettre un
coup d'arrêt à mk des playoffs et peyras
et perd alou qui en tête du cou oui
parce qu'il était quatrième montée à huy
donc en fait on regardait le leader ont
regardé leader du tournoi
alors est ce qu'on le suit contre cascio
à voir ci contre on peut regarder ce
qu'on n'a pas vu
poppy nattes ou paul pinaud thorn weepu
qui n'attend plus l'honneur pour le
pipeline à tort il était à la soirée à
paris là qu'on avait fait
d'ailleurs dès que le confinant dès que
ça s'est un peu arrangé toutes ces
histoires la mâture voir faire une
soirée 1 d'accord on va se refaire une
petite soirée alice qui loin
ouais je pense je pense après on peut
pas donner tâte mais a cessé une belle
soirée un concept est fait on est et on
était presque 200 je pense ce qui est
sympa pour progresser comme vous avez
jamais joué bien regardé quelques vidéos
d'initiation puis après faire un peu de
tactique quelques vidéos et commence à 8
c mais pas des cadences trop pour rapide
ça va vous énerver il faut prendre le
temps de réfléchir parce qu'elle aimait
les tournois de 15 minutes j'imagine
non mais tu peux faire les parties sur
child g en 15 minutes inscrits pour un
débutant je fonce c'est quand même mieux
que de faire 2 3 minutes
ouais moi je pense au minimum dix
minutes quand tu débutes mais c'est sain
et tu peux suivre la chaîne bitstream
est partie pédagogique les gens ils
disent que c'est ainsi que pédagogique
c'est très bien pour il ya tous niveaux
en plus c'est écrit dessus
ouais ça c'est les gens les gens ils me
disent que ça les aide vraiment beaucoup
pour pour débuter parce que ça leur
permet de voir un peu le raisonnement
ouais pas mal joué on n'est pas obligé
de jouer aux dames c est parce que
maintenant le fait partie correcte
les deux jeux pas trop mal mois les
bleus ont joué un petit morin avec un
des trois fous des deux mais bon des
folies des c'est peut-être simplement de
pousser le plomber peut-être kg 3 ici fo
et gsea ciel plombé le cube et c'est pas
mal dans le fond c'est pour le mettre au
b2 oui il ya beaucoup de gens qui jouent
maintenant mais moi quand je vous conte
des grands maîtres quoi qui joue avec
détroit contre la scandinave montmelas
jeu très souvent j'ai une partie contre
bruce sohn g1
je peins le parti d'aller voter je
collectionnais bandana te parler
mg ou bottes en fait c'est quoi c'est un
an c'est un ordi non c'est un bon mec
qui peut ajouter des réponses poser des
questions il peut faire pas mal de
choses mais c'est quoi c'est ils
configurent mais conclut ces trucs moi
je connais rien tel quel jeu les saint
calais possède à les sacrifier nos sur
ma chaîne perso c'est moi aussi qui les
semis configurer ce mon pote des formes
10 rajouter des choses sur ma chaîne
perso ca c les modos qu ils configurent
j'suis pas y rajoute des trucs je sais
même pas ce qu'ils font en fait c'est
qu'elle a un un je vais te remettre le
lien sérigraphes après on va aller je
pense comment faire je sais pas si on
est prévu de base de les faire les jours
des candidats simplement césar est là
mais peut-être on les fera tous les
jours pendant toute la durée des
candidats je vais voir avec chaises
comme ce qu'ils en pensent ne semble pas
réparable entre midi et deux là je suis
pas si vous kiffez mais ça me paraît
sympa comme un nom de ma femme m'a
préfères tu commences à 12h30
ouais vers 12h15 mais la poire en deux
du coup j'ai pas nombreux qu'est ce que
je voulais dire ouais moi je pourrais
pas tous les jours mais de temps en
temps avec les siens non on peut faire
un peu du mathieu un peu fab genre
demain je peux pas mais après pourquoi
ça serait mieux 13 15 ouais tu peux me
faire un sondage alors je peux faire 13
15 à partir de dimanche avec le
changement d'heure donc oui ça fait
après demain donc oui après demande
pourra faire 13 heures 13h06 mieux
hockey puisque est-ce que ça chauffe
tout le monde de serre 13 15 pendant
pendant la semaine là et puis on voit ce
que ça donne
on sait en fait on s'en fait trois
quatre dimanches lundis mardis et puis
après on en rediscute quoi ils n'ont les
blancs ici obtenu un petit avantage
frise ne le fouillez en b1
cela tourne bien le fond bk d'autres
points 3 c'est probablement un peu mieux
pour les blancs j'achète jamais revenir
sur youphil oui je préfère 13 15 ou même
14-16 donc 13 15 c'est bien je trouve
parce que ça permet aux gens quand même
qui font qu'ils veulent un peu regardés
pendant la pause midi pour ceux qui me
dit l'europe
wendy 12h30 13h fils y ont fait 13 15
toute façon tu la réunion là commencera
13h15 qu'on laisse toujours 15 minutes
de le temps de s'installer tout ça ok au
pire tu commences à 13h30
il est vrai qu'ils travaillent midi
dis-toi que joueur d'échecs ce la crise
mais entraîneur des chèques pourra être
utilisée sauvelade c'est pas la crise en
mai la faute et quatre non ouest fait
qu'il ya eu quatre d'emprunt apprend et
tu joues âge moyen on a un quart noir ou
prou inquiète donc le jeu sera moins
fort on dit oui mais 1,3 +0 1 jour
sérieux au moins une fois oui on va en
fait on fera on peut faire 5 + 0 3 + 0
et 3 plus de peu on peut tourner les
trois cas dans alibaba zoo après trois
puces des roses que je n'aime pas trop
c'est que ça exclut quand même les
joueurs plus faible à ça permet 5 0
quand même aux joueurs qui ont mille
mille cent mille deux cents pour faire
des parties quoi et quand tu viens de
commencer les 3 0 s'est fait vite en
panique way road préféré le système
suisse le problème du système suisse
dégâts c'est que si tu as des gens qui
arrivent en retard ils peuvent plus
participer au tournage aura finalement
on a 113 personnes qui joue et ça a
permis on était peut-être 40 au début ça
a permis à 70 personnes de venir se
greffer au tournoi après vous n'êtes pas
obligé de cliquer sur parties suivantes
immédiatement après votre parti si vous
souhaitez faire une petite pause oui
c'est un côté un peu plus ouais ok ils
ont gaffé ce dommage il était inconnu
un tour belle image et trouver du jeu
sont la colonne lettre b 1 avec les deux
font braquer
mais bon on s'en doute ce qu'a vu
revenir sur des cinq sa part refroidir
tic uturbey j'aime pas ça la fout des 33
j'aime pas la primaube et non il n'a pas
pris non plus ce que je sais c'est que
c'est une forme habituelle sens de la
couleur de l'été quand la couleur change
c'est que c'est moi ça veut pas dire que
le coût n'est pas joué pendant que des
mises sur l'échiquier qui il aurait très
bien pu jouer foot est roi et mais la
copine à tort qu'ils craquent sous la
pression mais c'est pas fait encore 1,2
calloc'h de moi y annonce
je veux bien se passer rapidement pour
combinator as-tu la sentir
là j'ai senti decailloz les mois à ouaga
oui c'est pas fait encore s'est pas fait
encore au nom il abandonne
il est même pas moins bien avec les
noirs bon il est un peu moins bien mais
non ça doit être ok cette adoption
tu as deux pions tour contre des
intérêts c'est dommage qu'il avant les
poulpes inattendu coup à temps peut il
et il en est ils en sont dans le tournoi
assez julien manants qui mène il a 9 sur
9 juin on a vu des jeunes way première
ronde il avait battu bombers il est
battu bombers et il est où il est là
attends je l'avais je l'avais il joué et
jouent contre samba près pas un nom
d'utilisateur il est content quoi elle
belles parties de poules pin à tort un
vous le pin a tort qui a fait de ta faim
mais d'ailleurs ça c'est si nulle que
j'ai joué pendant des années des années
avec les blancs j'avais un score de fou
mais objectivement c'est pas terrible
mais elle est là tu as un peu mieux des
cas c'était pas obligé tu peux te le
garder sous le coude
cette manoeuvre qu'elle est non je veux
très bien l'instant pour leurs lots
voilà peut-être un petit fou tour celui
de fougue et 8
si le foot i'm annoncé qu'il prendrait
un coquet et j'allais dire peut-être
dame décide d'abord pour manoeuvre sur
17 pour contrôler aussi ces gars notre
plus grande faiblesse
mais allez commencer par dame de notre g
8 tours s'est vite je préfère et noir
fumant jouer avec les grands pas ouais
moi aussi je dégueule dégueulasse mais
victor à la fin elle a d'ailleurs ce que
tu as fait mais juste a gaffé deux
qualités d'affilée ces deux de trop
c'est vrai quoi mais huit ok bien joué
ils se regroupent
ouais bien je suis tour c4 maintenant
peut être une idée parce que des
douilles à 34 je résume un gala j'ai mal
je suis pas sûr pour la gagnerai cet
aréna mathurin ça joue quand même pas
mal hein je serais allé un jour tu la
joie si j'aime pas blessé - ouais je
pense que tu sera en grand danger en
face à l'élite h4 pas mal joué mais ont
peut-être fait retour j'ai vite
maintenant 4 enfin je veux tenter de
faire quelque chose j'en sais rien
peut-être cavalier a fit même mais je
pense que la torah doit aller en g8
justin pression oui oui tour euh oui je
suis d'accord tour 8 c'était pas la case
de l'atome mais je pense tour ses quatre
tours ce 8e c'est de simplifier puisque
les finales voire sont dotés de bonnes
non que oui au tour ses quatre tours
s'est vite mais les tours 8 c'était
vraiment ça ok ça c'est le responsable
sillage 5 et une grosse question jeudi
la cage et cinq mois ça qui m'inquiète
soto il ya tout qui m'inquiète c'est un
autre côté c'était pas mauvais
probablement que si comme il prend des
pions j'imagine pour jouer des quatre
mètres carrés sa gamme g4 bien les
coudes attaques vont arriver assez
rapidement il va lire avec et prend des
cinq à dix ou qui reprend du fou ouais
c'est pas empêché de calais devenir
sujet simple mais c'est un peu moche
d'un g4 veut prendre
c'est peut être ma chance est sûre je
pense qu'il est faire damas deux en fait
ici demain 2 j'avais peur mais tord c4
et c4 c'était pas mal ouais
pour ces quatre secteurs ce qui marche
ce qu'il fait ouais c'est chaud de d2 il
ya d'un prochain 21 d'emprunt un bon nom
ouais tu prends rejoints deux fois et je
prends ces trois là fin d'un âge et kate
ont ce qui sépare d une pièce mais à la
fin est la mesure phare est ce que tu
peux pas prendre prendre prendre mettre
ton car ayant réussi ce tube l'inde tout
si tu me l'as v club show 4 que veut lui
aussi ce drogué ni assurance et 3 tu as
eu des quatre il ya peut-être fou des
deux voies la tour 1 mais on attendait
juste mieux
oui oui mais je la foux des deux têtes
sather et si on fait des cartes ici à la
dame je saute dans le premier set donc
ça serait une erreur donc vous qui avez
aussi c'est four chaud d'un haletant au
foot et d'eau feront probablement un bon
coup oui c'est peut-être food et tu
pourras peut-être faire fou des deux
tours car elle était un débat des cut
justice sert à rien quoi menacer en fait
il y avait lui aussi empêche tout
contrôle jouer les monstres
il a fait rage deux décades mauvaise et
très bon pas grave il faut premières
fuites ouais ouais ouais c'est dommage
mais je pense 8 et gagne 1 joseph encore
jouer un peu un forfait retour ca et
passive est pur jeu des trois vraiment
ipad damien qu'à 3 f 7
oui mais peut-être foot est ici ça a
quitté damas à damas fuite matt champion
et à 9,7
c'est probablement maintenant je peux
commandes a investi ce sujet cette no 6
se fout de cette matin au caire que
julien est pas mal il est pas mal mais
il ya des gens qui sont passés devant il
va leur passer devant
dhainaut lyon n'a toujours pas besoin
d'innover en nature pas vu mais en fait
les premiers ce jeu pont entre ce soit
ça c'est le problème c'est que c'est un
des défauts de ses arénas c'est que ça
se joue tu veux des gens qui ont un
hello proche et pas forcément les autres
leaders c'est un truc j'ai demandé plein
de fois qu'ils le change ça devrait être
modifié en fait à paris à vélo son homme
qu'elle est probable bah c'est pas que
cet oxymore donc il joue sa son
répertoire ainsi soit je mettre le lien
de la reina mais reste plus que huit
minutes
vous avez très chaud mais juliel à 10
sur 10 mais truc c'est comme il gagne
pas très rapidement c'est parti mais il
peut se faire il peut se faire doubler
et derrière marc quand ils arrêtent et
non aux arts aux arts hoarau à ronan
sajoo arrow sens qu'il me sur 6 mais
peut-être que non mais peut-être qu'il a
arrêté en fait mais sicile en train de
jouer un rôle il a dit faire une pause
ou kim tae joue contre bombers attend
c'est intéressant cette fin de partie
surtout que les joueurs se sont joués il
ya pas si longtemps donc je sais qu'ici
mais c'est pas les plans qu'ils sont
viables s'ils sont loin de trouver ces
sept c'est sacré
gay et c'est surréaliste
j'arrive tour d2 ça va être un coup ces
sept
je courais ce qui se passait sur ces 7
honnêtement quand tu veux y mettre un
coup d'ordi on a peut-être qu'ils sont
quand même fort non non ses sept tours à
roye ces deux tours c'est huit mois et
aura sept prochains mais puisque tu peux
pas l'enlever de hockey
mazet bien que dans son mémo no way mais
ce n'est pas fait encore dit tu peux
faire cliquez ici cette messe a pas plus
loin que le début j'attends thème de
l'ombre pas théorique c'est ça si ça
peut te rassurer
ouais ça peut le trouver un corps et un
attrait 150 qui trouvent tous les
meilleurs coups c'est normal c'est qu'il
est coréen nous et qui les 1350 de l'ua
ne franchisse un vrai plus et ff 6 6 e 5
m6 11 à 3 et si tu touches tu ramènes
leroy ou qui en fait je touche à rien
pour ces cinq peut-être projet cinq mois
et pour le moment il menace rien moi
mais je voulais éviter ce coûte 1 et
tours c5 va faire rapprocher qu'à trois
c4 c4 en descendant sur un cavalier de
saint cloud à bord mayroy entre 4,3 g 3
1 bref c'est un guy c'est pas con
c'est en ça que j'ai fait roi c4 d'abord
et pas à laisser bonjour a fêté ses 5
mai avant que c'est cette hockey sur roy
prend il veut quoi à l'aïe fait ce qu'il
peut faut pas beaucoup au caire il peut
plus rien à tour à sept cas il est si
c'est ça son esprit mais je prends comme
ça ok très vite mais c'est peut-être
perdre en gamme
je me le rend le sang qui fâche un ouais
ok prise prise prise à 5 3 3
4' trois des quatre gagnants pannonia
tour des musiciens un tour des 8 reprend
m se trouvant en arrache cette non 3g 6
2,6 à non je pense que tant francis
albany ce que là il fait on prend un
accès 3g 6 il a fait trois c4 a pris la
page a3 tours b 8 de la perdre il monte
le roi adverse mais j'ai pas vu le temps
on a vu qu'elle énonce sont mauvais à la
souris auquel il fait refaire les seins
canon ça va faire nul non je pense blanc
ont gagné quelques jours de roy à 3 il a
refusé nul mais je pensais alors ses
huîtres la batterie exprès de refuser
les tours s'est vite trouvé huit tombes
et va tomber avec l'emprunt il veut
faire du propos tenus il faut bouillir
un cap cet été peuvent s'échanger les
tours non non ça jusqu'à la mort mais
n'en est pas si sûr
ainsi viser le sourire
il est malin avec les noirs il est plus
rapide mais est gnata et s est mis en
pré move nul bourse américaine c'est un
résultat logique elle partira tant qu
est-ce qui joue là devant il ya joseph
michel qui était tellement de partie
avec russie qui joue pas les forces a
bel et bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr alors
attends qui pourrait le rattraper ce
serait julien qui pourrait le rattraper
3g voir julien et il faut qu'on trouve
julien surtout il joue pas je vois plus
c'est julien et c'est julien combien
c'est julien 21
il est la troisième équipe qui gagne
mais non il arrivera pas ice contre
joseph michel en plus on ne peut pas le
rattraper la sicile de bah ouais mais il
reste plus de 8 dans le tournoi donc là
partira pas le temps de se finir à ses
marques quand il m'a expliqué quéré ça
s'est joué à ça parce qu'ils avaient une
bonne de plus et ça marche pas tu donc
sert que le seul qui peut recoller à
joseph seibert à l'eau donc c'est que
berra look il faut aller voir des rats
l'opéra l'opéra l'opéra l'eau il est là
il peut le faire
il peut levaï là il joue vite hein il
joue vite ouest avenue de wagram dans le
tournoi il est très mal mini wheat un
bacille autre ton il peut rattraper à
annonce avait bien jeune
ok mais là il prend trop de temps
beraldo il a k'un de trois milles
d'avancé apens de waimes et regarde il
reste plus qu'une minute 10 dans le ton
a donc il faut qu'ils fassent tomber
face et lui c'est comme s'il avait dix
secondes là en fait il est obligé d'être
fou le pré move ouais mais là il va
tomber et je veux quand même la gueule
qui tenta un match du couloir un truc
h33 je pense et fin du tournoi 6
tu approches cette dame d1 il y revient
au score à chaud je crois je pense que
là c'est sans doute au moins 23 change
c'est là que ça va marcher mais bon
enfin du temps à vera l'eau qui finira 1
sauf si les mecs se déconnecte à nancy
se déconnecter mais bon il va pas perdre
à l'eau la partie festive a laissé le
temps coule et ça va faire nul face à a
perdu ça va pas finir la partie mais ils
savent semaine
ouais bien sûr c'est des habitués ils
connaissent pas tissé qui prend aucun
risque et donc du coup la dernière je
peux faire vraiment n'importe quoi ils
invitent pour espérer gagner une tonne
un mois ça va arriver de finir sur un
match du berger contre ammann hambleton
il nous resterait ces genres 25 secondes
dans le tournoi on prélevait tous les
deux et je vais faire une dame price à
être un truc comme ça
ce qu'ils savaient que pour les ducs
août avait maté avant la fin du tournoi
ouais j'ai également la famille temps
après les gens qui sont vraiment hyper
expérimentés ils font en fait ils jouent
entre eux ils font çà çà çà çà çà çà et
ils font une répétition rapide de trop
ça fait trois fois et comme ça tu prend
un point et tu fais ça compte ou les
adversaires pour réussir à monter quoi
pourquoi on fait pas un tournoi par on à
partir de maintenant le tueur j'ai déjà
expliqué tout à l'heure c'est pour que
les gens puissent venir à n'importe quel
moment et participer au tournoi pour
voir qu'on soit bloquée et de toute
façon là si tu veux faire comme un
tournoi par honte tu peux simplement à
ne pas ne pas recommencer une partie
directement quoi
alors une petite question aura rennes
avec les noirs je joue française et
hollandaise avec le 6 mai je sais pas
quoi jouer avec les blancs une idée 3,4
pas qu'on imagine images de disquette
moussa mais un objectif à l'info à
prendre un répertoire classique un gain
de 4-1 ce système de lure le cadre des
diamond saurait après brooklyn mon tête
après le confinement mais mais bon c'est
pas compte quand ça aura lieu parce
qu'il faut vraiment que l'épidémie
s'arrête serre si le confinement
s'arrête gym bêtise le 25 avril que nous
refaire une soirée le 15 juin mais que
en réalité l'épidémie elle repart trois
semaines après c'est un peu bête ou quoi
oui il faut faire un peu gaffe on va
attendre que soient bien finie comme il
faut et puis on verra on verra par la
suite
donc du coup normalement prochaine fois
ce sera dimanche 1
donc ouais enfin on verra quoi fin
demain annonce que moi même je sais pas
si on autant de moi demain
bon mais où cela soit dimanche à 13h
soit demain à voir je vais voir avec
chace comme s'ils nous disent ok
continuer cette petite tradition des
tournois si on arrête j'espère ce n'est
plus si vous avez d'autres questions et
suggestions n'hésitez pas partie
pédagogique
ouais on pourrait faire ça mais là c'est
sympa ça change un peu la le tournoi se
trouve vu que via le confinement je
trouve ça faisait quelque chose de
nouveau parce que si on fait tous les
jours des parties pédagogique on va en
avoir marre aussi
ça permettait d'avoir un autre un autre
format mais si tu veux des vienne un
jour tu me dire ah ouais de mieux tu
pense qu'elle sera chaude pour commenter
ou pas
le monsieur la peau terre si pas compris
ap l'auteur c'est ce fait clara tant que
c'est une ouverture dans une ouverture
c'est ça mais c'est mieux c'est un très
intéressant pour les bains où j'ai gagné
plug start i a bloqué lundi
l'étude des ouvertures m écoute enfin
pas non plus c'est pas est ce pas fait
pour être des courses et stream c'est
fait pour être quelque chose quand même
de ludique
le but du tout c'est pas de faire de
pause mais d'abord tout seulement de
particules de torture je comprends mais
en fait on peut pas un objectif c'est de
s'amuser il n'y a pas de prix ou glams
d'argent qu'il ya pas de prix et loeb
victime tournoi c'est plus de jouer
c'est un plaisir et comme ça on peut
commenter quelques parties c'est pas
forcément de gagner
le 10 mai jean c'est que les gens
puissent rentrer dans le temps à contis
veulent qu'ils puissent en sortir quand
ils veulent et si tu fais un tour
apparence adjoint d'arriver à une heure
précise de jouer pendant un temps précis
là les gars y viennent ils rentrent dans
le tournoi il sortir en deçà permet que
de faire juste des partis et de et de
jouer et de s'amuser c'est pas c'est pas
le championnat du monde d'échecs ya pas
il n'y a pas de titre ou de vol dont le
way l'objectif c'est de s'amuser quoi
bomber sur ce match
écoutons houssin dimanche près de 10 des
11 il tâta dimanche on se dit apte à
dimanche pour la prochaine et ça ouais
suivez suivent et oui twitter le twitter
de chess comme quoi et on va on va voir
comment s'organise exactement c'est pas
facile vu les conditions de faire les
plannings de tout faire et beaucoup de
chose qui s'organise aussi du côté de
chasse comme de leur côté on n'est pas
franc toujours au courant de ce qu'ils
inventent mais parce que où ils devaient
enfin il n'avait pas prévu ça personne
n'avait prévu donc il faut un petit
temps d'adaptation voir combien de gens
qui regardent et c'est donc on va
regarder tout ça aussi le japon allait
en entendant on en reparlera on aura le
temps donc merci